hi I'm farmer Brad and I'm in the high
tunnel the next step
install some irrigation now I already
had this header pipe it's a lay flat
pipe of two inches in diameter and what
I'm gonna do is right behind here is
where the water tower is gonna be so the
water tower will gravity feed down here
but I want to leave this door open so I
can drop my tractor up and down so what
I'm gonna do is run this two-inch pipe
all the way down to the end of the high
tunnel I'll do a 90 and then I'll run
three-quarter inch hose across the end
and then that will end up feeding the
drip tape now I want to bring to your
attention company name dripworks they
specialize in irrigation drip tapes
small and large and they were kind
enough to donate 500 feet of
three-quarter inch poly pipe and that
will run from the ramp pump through the
water tower they also include a
medium-sized irrigation system for a
high tunnel that I'll be using in the
next couple videos but today's goal is
getting this hooked up to the garden
hose
initially and then eventually this
two-inch will connect to the water tower
this will at least get the irrigation
system up and running and then I'll take
you along for the rest of things so make
sure to check out dripworks com for all
of your irrigation needs and definitely
want to thank them for their sponsorship
of these irrigation videos so without
further ado I'll go ahead and start the
process okay so the first thing I'll do
is I'll put this 90 degree on and what
eventually this will happen is it will
go vertical up to the water tower but at
least for now I'll just run a short
little section of hose and then I'll be
able to connect connect it on to here
I'll just cut a section here then sure
to put on one of those clamps if it is a
really snug fit you can take a torch and
heat it up to stretch it I'll cut
another little section here
and then lastly another hose clamp and
put this right here
okay so I'm gonna tighten up this hose
clamp
[Music]
Oh
okay so that's on there I'll go ahead
and hook up the garden hose so I'm using
the same garden hose adapter they used
for the automatic chicken water buckets
and just does a safety measure
I'll put teflon tape on this part so
then I'll take my channel locks channel
locks and hang it up as tight as I can
okay
I'm gonna move this back into position
we'd be up against there now let's go to
the other end so I'm gonna find a spot
over here probably like right about
there to tie this in
before I got any further I wanted to go
over the medium-sized irrigation system
for high tunnel so it includes I think a
hundred feet of half-inch poly pipe and
this is what I'll use to feed the drip
tape well it has a filter here it has
where you can splice into here to run
the drip tape it has spikes for keeping
the irrigation in place see oh these are
for tying off the ends of the drip tape
so you can terminate them by just
flipping them over in half and then
these are little plastic pieces that
slide over the end and then here are
some pressure regulators to decrease the
pressure from pressure regulator down to
10 psi so you don't over blow your
system there's a little puncture tool or
puncturing the holes in this to connect
these little parts and then there's also
some repair kits where if there's a hole
you can cut the leaking area and then
splice the two parts together so that's
pretty much what is included in the
system they also which I'm really
excited about this drip works provide me
with a Bluetooth hose end irrigation
controller so this you'll be able to
control via bluetooth set the schedules
as long as you're within range of
Bluetooth so that will be really awesome
so then I can set timing for watering
and the such so unfortunately I don't
have another clamp so I'm just going to
try to terminate this by doing the
pullback method and some Gorilla Tape
wait these arrow there is back there we
go so that should terminate that
[Music]
where that will do the trick for that
now here I'm going to unscrew this and
have it go from three-quarter inch down
to half an inch okay so now I'm going to
heat this up a little bit
light it on there
[Music]
and then I'll do the
same thing up here
[Music]
okay okay so I'm gonna connect this
first over here okay keep this up
okay that's tight
I'll go ahead and take one of these too
I'll keep it straight
[Music]
okay so determine and eat this end what
I'll do is I'll cut this off and I'll
flip it back so because this hose is
pretty tight I'm going to just use this
clamp here to
[Music]
[Applause]
this is where the video is gonna have to
end I wasn't able to get any further
because there was a storm coming in
so look forward to irrigation part 2 in
an upcoming video thanks for watching